hi guys it's ria today we are making
strawberry showcake
[Music]
so in japan we eat strawberry shortcake
in any kind of celebratory occasions
birthdays graduation
christmas even when i hear strawberry
showcake i immediately think of sponge
cake with cream and strawberry on top
this is japanese version and i want to
show you how to make it today i need
four eggs and i'm using warm water so
eggs become room temperature quickly i'm
already preheating my oven for 350
fahrenheit set aside so you have
parchment paper fold like triangle and
this corner to the other corner
hold on the corner
find the middle and cut right here and
you made a circle perfectly fits in a
mold line on the bottom and you also
want to line on the side so cut the
knife and line the side and ready and
let's move on i have 40 gram of milk and
40 gram of butter and i'm gonna just use
microwave to melt butter completely okay
so prep is done i have room temperature
eggs and hot water bath let's crux egg
so the reason we are using room
temperature egg because it's a little
bit easier to whip up so i have 95 grams
of sugar whip this until kind of pale
color like five to eight minutes i want
to make sure the temperature is about 85
fahrenheit i'm adding honey
you start seeing this is becoming like
very volumey kind of draw eight like
whatever you want your initial smiley
face and if you can still see the line
and it's kind of disappearing like a
couple seconds that's ready i have been
whisking with high speed so i'm going to
lower the speed and mix another two to
three minutes so the bubble becomes
smaller so when you bake the cake you
don't see big bubble in a baked sponge
cake i want to make sure the cake is not
dry so honey milk butter helps cake keep
moist now i'm going to add some flour we
want to shift the cake flour so you
don't have big chunk of flour in a
mixture you kind of want to mix it with
rubber spatula until flower is well
incorporated it's about 30 to 40 times
if you never made a cake before i'm
adding milk and butter mixture and make
sure this is warm
not too hot so i'm kind of using spatula
spreading milk and butter mixture
another like 40 to 50 times okay butter
is ready and i'm going to put in a mold
and bake the cake just pour all the
butter and then you want to drop like
high place
like two or three times
kind of removing big bubbles and i'm
going to lower the temperature 320
fahrenheit bake the cake for 30 to 35
minutes until it's nice brown color
while the cake is baking let's prep
decorations we are going to use
strawberries take off the top
and if you have bigger one we gonna cut
kind of same
size when i bake i like to listen like
old jazz music kind of channeling old
grandma who is good at baking
cake is beautifully baked and it's rised
nicely because of the power of eggs and
i want to make sure it's cooked through
and it came out clean so it's fully
baked you want to drop it
two times so it will prevent shrinking
while we are waiting for cooling down
let's sweep some cream 500 grams of
heavy cream 75 gram of sugar and i have
vanilla 1 teaspoon i like whipping cream
with whisk so i can control the texture
it's going to take time though and you
want to
whisk until
stiff peak
white stiff peak why it's not it's a
hard peak the other day i said i'm
introvert and i told alex you are outro
bart
get in there
i feel like my right arm is gonna get
bigger than my left toe
all right cool so i'm gonna just keep in
the fridge until i use it and let's
decorate the cake so cake is cool to
touch so i'm going to flip and
peel
i'm going to cut in a half moving the
blade little by little yeah
nice
we have time table it's easy to decorate
and we have cake board
so the cream doesn't get on too much of
the surface so this is kind of ugly part
so i'm going to put on the bottom so
nobody sees it and i'm using
ball scraper we have small offset
spatula i'm gonna just spread the cream
evenly you don't want to put too much
cream at this point just like a nice
even layer
and we have the cut strawberry
laying down
i want to make sure each bite has a
strawberry you know
you get strawberry you get strawberry so
strawberry is laid out and i'm going to
put more cream on top and you're going
to put the last one you know whip a
little more
kind of spread with little offset
spatula
go down
make sure the sides get enough cream
it's getting a little bit trickier than
butter cream because it's all whipped
cream
and from now i'm going to just clean
cleaning up as part of cake decorating
when you kind of make it look really
smooth it's very satisfying put the ball
scraper close to you and kind of like
load it in and don't move your right
hand too much
it's kind of like a frost coat we are
doing like second coat i think
decorating cake is something you have to
practice many times you have to be very
patient i'm still learning how to
decorate cakes you know this is kind of
handmade cake so it doesn't need to be
perfect i think so if you're also
stressed don't stress too much
we have some leftover cream so i'm going
to pipe on top so i have a piping bag i
want to twist and insert into the piping
tip
you can hold it with your hand or you
can use tall glass
and add the cream i'm gonna pipe
all right
and put strawberries
okay just simple as that we made a
strawberry showcake right cheers
it's just like simple but delicious i
love this showcake because it's not too
sweet and it kind of reminds me of my
birthday christmas and just happy memory
i highly encourage you to make it when
you make it tag me on instagram and
thank you for watching
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you